hi everyone I am Elena Australian a data
scientist from Easy the marks AI team
and in Easy the Mark we provide products
for email security and deliverability
and today I want to walk you through the
AI Power Solutions that are made that
are built in is it the mark for the sake
of Seiko of cyber security
uh in this talk you will learn about AI
challenges and the challenges that it
has in the field of cyber security
then we will go to the topic of
preventing spoofing attacks and some
data specifics that are within this
challenge then we will move on to one of
the most important topics in cyber
security the web fishing detection by
discussing its data specifics then we
will go to the data preprocessing of it
and
we will move on to the feature
extraction and the challenges within it
and then we will check the final results
that we have at easydmark and uh see the
accuracies and the metrics that it has
already on the production
so Ai and cybertext if we divide the
machine learning into those main Fields
the supervised learning the supervised
learning self-supervised learning and
reinforcement learning we see that uh AI
has a lot of topics a lot of gaps to
cover in the field of cyber security for
example in case of unsupervised learning
uh we have the problem of anomaly
detection spoofing attacks phishing
detection or spoofing risk estimation
and this is most in most of the cases is
a task for unsupervised learning because
we in general do not have much data and
much label data in this field
for the supervised learning we have the
problems of fishing detection again
because in some cases you have labeled
data we have spoofing detection also
uh the data quality checks pump filters
uh and so on and so forth uh for the
case of reinforcement learning for
example network monitoring the patterns
always change and you need to detect the
zero day attacks and for this uh you
need reinforcement learning to be up to
date to always train your model to know
the new challenges also the adversial
text
searching agent and decision agents for
detection of those cyber attacks for
self-supervised learning
we want to mention the problems of
predictive maintenance uh the look-alike
attacks and email body classification
because in those cases you have some
techniques techniques to label your data
and not having label data is not a
problem
um
and in easy to Mark we provide solutions
for spoofing risk eliminations proofing
attack detection anomaly detection look
like attack detection data quality check
and of course web fishing detection on
which we will mainly focus in this talk
and I want to show a couple of solutions
that we have and the first one is the
spoofing attack detection namely
lookalike and display names for fling uh
detection
first of all let's understand what are
spoofing attacks
uh we can see here an email account of
John Smith and this is the display names
proofing
and this is the display name and here is
the email of John Smith at example.com
and in case of the namesproofing attacks
the attacker tries to have a very
similar display name but a different
email the thing is that the users the
people who get a new email they do not
in general pay attention on the email
that they are receiving from and they
only look at the display name and think
okay this is the real John Smith and uh
that's how they are getting attacked in
the case of lookalike attacks uh uh if
you look uh at the this display name it
can match and uh if you look at the
email it or at the first glance it can
also match but if you look further you
can see you can notice some letter
substitutions some letter emissions and
this is how the lookalike attacks are
being done so for example in this case
the letter uh m is substituted by the
letters r and then so uh if you looking
at the screen of the phone you will not
notice this and you will get attacked by
the uh by the lookalike attacks so we
provide solution uh to pre uh to to help
your employees uh emails to be secure uh
from uh display name spoofing and your
domain is to be secured from lookalike
attacks uh by providing solutions that
use both NLP and computer vision
techniques and the reason behind this is
that we have a lot of data specifics a
lot of challenges that need to be
addressed
uh
oops so for example
one data specific that we have here is a
data labeling we do not have much data
and it is not easy to gather a lot of
data for the for the spoofing attacks
also there are millions of permutations
for the display names proofing for
example for for example the John Smith
can be written as Smith Jones and this
also can be considered as name spoofing
there are millions of tricky methods
to substitute the letters from your
domain and this is another challenge and
last but not least that I want to
mention is that there are different
alphabets that look very similar and you
can't tell the difference
and this is the main reason that we also
use computer vision techniques not only
NLP to cover all of those data specifics
but uh for the solution I don't want to
go much in details uh in the solution
because we have a lot of to talk about
the URL and website phishing detection
so uh website and uh phishing the
website phishing detection it is very
important because if we look at this
phishing Statistics we can see that the
number of phishing websites uh increased
in the last five six years very
drastically and this is according to
statistics retract from the Google safe
browsing
um
and on the y-axis you can see the number
of websites and on the x-axis you can
see the date and uh the phishing
websites increase but the malware
websites did not so we can understand
that cyber attacks attackers are more
interested in phishing attacks because
they are pretty successful if we look at
this statistic uh which is retract from
statista and uh this survey is done in
2020 and 600 organizations were asked if
they
had a successful phishing attack if they
experienced one and more than 50 percent
of them said that yes they actually
experienced experienced a successful
phishing attack so not only the fishing
attacks become more and more but they
are actually very dangerous and they are
successful and the results of them are
much worse we because the those
organizations said that 60 of them lost
data 52 percent of them had credentials
or accounts compromised 47 of them were
infected with ransomware 20 of them 29
of them with malware and 18 of those 18
of those organizations were experienced
they experienced Financial losses
so phishing attacks are pretty dangerous
and they need to be addressed as quick
as possible
uh so but before going into the solution
we need to understand the data specifics
uh to thoroughly do the data
preprocessing and understand what
features can help us uh in this solution
uh the first thing that we need to
understand is that we are going to work
with both Text data and image data so uh
the problem becomes double uh also the
same information can be expressed in
different ways can be it can be
expressed expressed with images it can
be expressed with text and grasping the
content the context out of those website
components it is very hard task
also hidden details are seen only in
comparison look at this fake Google
website okay you look at it you think
okay this is uh trying to replicate the
Google Website and uh you understand
that this is probably a phishing website
but you will not uh think about this if
you will not uh know about Google that
like the real Google so those
comparisons are necessary and we need to
make sure that our algorithm knows about
Google the real Google
ah also the texts in the websites are in
different languages and uh you cannot uh
be like your solution cannot be based
only on NLP or only on the content
because uh you cannot cover all the
languages and you have you will have a
lot of gaps
also uh some symbols in some websites
are okay and some in others are not and
a universal pattern uh is very hard to
understand so for example a dog Emoji
can be very okay in a website that is
all about dogs but it cannot be okay in
a website that is about uh that there is
a for example login page for some social
media uh website
uh also
some other data specific the URL links
because in general big problems and we
need uh to make sure uh to understand
what are the URL links in our data set
because they cause zero feature vectors
about which I will talk later
uh also the latency for extracting
features from the website content
uh we should pay attention on it because
it takes a lot of time
also Messi coach
our model our feature extraction should
not be based on the cost structure
because there are a lot of developers
that do not follow the designs of uh
main coding Styles and uh you cannot uh
understand whether it is a phishing
website which was done very quickly or
it is a normal website
also phishing patterns always change
they are changing every day and we will
see
um the metrics of our model and prove
that uh this is a thing
so after understanding the their
specifics we need to move on to the data
preprocessing part
uh the first thing that we need to uh
pay attention to is making the URLs
canonical
the data sets that you get come in
different ways for example in one of
your data set you can have the URLs on
the domains you can have very deep messy
URLs and you need for example you can
have the WW subdomain in some URLs in
some they are not existing and
you should make sure that they all look
the same and hence reduce the noise
because for example you you do not need
the information about the www subdomain
uh also uh you need to check the
distributions of HTTP https protocols to
make sure that your data is well
balanced uh because if you have a lot of
HD uh love a lot of URLs that have https
protocol and they are all legitimate
URLs you will have a bias in your model
also you need to check the distribution
of the number of characters or the
combination of those characters
and understand what are the most common
tokens in your data set
and you need to pay attention on the URL
links again uh to make sure you don't
have only very long URLs and you don't
have only short URLs and also the depth
of the URLs you need to make sure you
need to avoid having only domain URLs or
some only messy urls
and then after checking this you can
remove the most common tokens the most
common things uh and considering them as
top words
and then go to the part of extracting
content from the website itself going
and scraping those components
uh now let's move to the feature
extraction and after a good data
preprocessing after reducing the noise
first thing that we need to do is
extracting features
the first approach that we thought would
be very helpful was lexical features
and by saying lexical we mean that those
features are only retrieved from the URL
string and for example those features
can be the URL length the number of
dashes the number of some symbols and
those those features grasp the pattern
very well for the long URLs but they do
not work for the short URLs because for
the short URLs we don't have plays for
those features and we have very uh many
we have many zero Factor zero feature
vectors we have a data scarcity and a we
are office it will lose data so uh we
need to
make sure that our features are not
based on the URL length
that is why we think we thought that
tokenizing is a better solution and by
tokenizing we mean splitting the string
to different parts for example you can
split by the protocol HTTP or https you
can split by the subdomain by the root
domain or the main domain you can also
split the different parts of the URLs or
you can split by some symbols and hence
grasp some words out of the URL
and after
tokenizing our URLs we should vectorize
it so our model will understand those
tokens we should make them into the
numbers
uh all of the vectors known
vectorization techniques uh work well
with different models we tried the
simplest one hot encoding we tried word
to back tfid effectorization python
biting coding and even we tried the
encoding blocks of Transformer models
and
in vectorization process we should
always not forget about
including the uh the the the the weight
of the tokens of two or more different
tokens combined and you can do this by
using the techniques of engrams keepgram
or you can add some terms in the in the
prediction model that will describe the
the the the effect
uh so after uh tokenization we vectorize
our URLs and a fit to a neural network
uh and then understand if the URL is a
phishing or not
but uh this is all good this worked well
and uh pay attention on on that part
that it is only using features from the
URL
and why we are only trying to uh extract
features from the URL because it enables
a fast detection
also it needs a lower computational uh
Power because we don't go into the
website and uh grasp and like use a lot
of computational power uh to parse those
websites also we believe that patterns
tell a lot
but more sophisticated phishing attacks
require more sophisticated Solutions
because there are some examples that
prove us that only by looking at the
URLs we cannot understand fully if it's
sufficient or not so when we go into the
website for example this first one
it's a really nice website it has the
https protocol it has a very nice domain
but when you go into the website you
understand that this does not match the
URL that it has
and in fact this is the phishing of
their website from the right part
and we would not understand this but
without going into the website
also we have the problem from the other
way around where we have messy urls but
we have legitimate websites for example
this one is the PayPal's official login
page it looks massive from the first
glance but it is the legitimate one
so we need to also touch the content of
the website and we should pay attention
on the clickable buttons uh the URLs the
hyperlinks in it and the relation
relations between those URLs the
original URL and the website content uh
to understand to grasp those uh fishy
components
and the important thing that we should
pay attention mostly on the relations
not the components separately
uh so these are good we have our
features uh both from the website both
from the and and from the URL only uh
but there are some challenges in those
feature extraction especially for the
URL phishing detection because uh first
of all we need to get the final URLs we
need to have some responses out of those
URLs in order to understand those
features uh and uh in general uh
requesting those URLs take a lot of time
that's why uh in these cases we need to
use asynchronous requests in order to
make minimize the waiting time in uh in
in in in this request so
a small piece of code that I want to
show you first we see the word async in
front of the dev function and this means
that we have qualities asynchronous
functions uh and uh here we Define a
timeout for our client that will make a
direct throughout which we will make the
request to our urls
and then we open one client session uh
pay attention on this that we only uh
create a session once so we will also
minimize the waiting time here because
if we open a client session for each
request it will take enormous time
so we open the one one session and using
the asyncure gather function which is
from the asyncho library
we start getting those urls
uh also I forgot to mention that the
client that we are using is from IO HTTP
HTTP Library
uh now let's look at the other function
uh this is for getting those URLs uh
throughout this uh client session
so iuhttp client session enables us to
get those uh URLs without having
blocking processes so it will not block
the times when you have to wait for your
response so you just use the uh asyncos
IO https get method and get your URL and
wait for your response without actually
waiting without blocking the other
processes so you can move on to the uh
to requesting the other URLs and here in
the next lines I am retrieving the final
URLs of my original URL but you can put
the scraping part here so you will make
you will minimize the waiting time more
so it's nice we got the responses uh
from our URLs very quickly and in this
case for example if you have 100 URLs to
request and the longest response time
takes around three seconds uh requesting
all those 100 URLs will take only three
seconds
uh and after this when we get our
responses we need to parse those content
this content from our responses and if
we use Beautiful soap Library I'm sure
you are all familiar with this
I have some tips that you can use to
make it faster the first thing I want to
mention is the soup strainer which is uh
for parsing only the text only the
elements that you will need in your
in your processing
and the second thing is the C sharded
Library which is universal encoding
character uh detection detector and by
installing and importing this uh
beautiful soup with become 10 times
faster and this is also claimed in the
beautiful Source documentation
uh also you should use lxml sparsync not
the HTML parser because it is also much
faster and a last thing that I already
mentioned is asynchronous request you
asynchronously requesting those URLs uh
getting sweeping the responses very
quickly and then move on to your model
so our final model our current model is
based on the
tokenization vectorization and layers
and neural network
and we are doing our model evaluation by
two methods the first one is false
prediction monitoring and also we are
doing daily monitoring on open fish data
set and fish tank data set
uh let's look at the metrics we have uh
so this chart is showing the accuracy of
our model starting from December 2021 uh
till August 2022
and we can see that the accuracy of our
model
is around 95 percent on average for the
whole time uh we have of course bombs
because Putters change but still it is
around 95 percent
uh also if we look at the false
predictions uh we again are around 95
accuracy according to our users uh and
we went live on March of 2022 and
starting from them we didn't uh have a
low accurate much lower accuracies
uh you can also check our phishing URL
checker on our website is itthemark.com
and give your feedback uh if you think
that this URL is uh predicted uh well or
not and your feedback will be very
helpful
so uh to summarize we achieved complex
and successful uh phishing detection
solution with 95 accuracy on average and
we did this by thoroughly understanding
the data specifics by not ignoring them
uh by uh good noise reduction and data
preprocessing and feature extraction and
feature and using features that are not
based on the URL links uh also I want to
mention that we are already healthier in
production and we
pursue this 95 accuracy for the whole
time and I want uh to also mention that
there is still a lot to cover in the
field of cyber security for the ml
so uh I want to thank you for the
attention and uh thank our other
contributors armandochan and hi
collection if you have any questions
that we will not manage to answer now
you can ask uh by writing to my email
and that's it thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you for the presentation I have a
couple of technical questions here
so for the URLs that you are
taking uh at the beginning you must have
the good URLs and the bad URLs to to
labelize right yeah it's all about
supervised learning all about supervised
learning so for training your your model
or your architecture
what is uh from where did you get your
for example the good URLs and what data
is that and what data set you got the
bad URLs for example for the pitching uh
fishing or
deformant URLs and stuff like this what
data sets did you use at the beginning
we did not use only one data set we use
multiple
multiple sets for example the
data set the fish tank that opened and
open fish I mentioned and several others
that we also gathered and uh by
combining all of those data sets we got
our final one which is uh and we have
around
the number of our data set is around
it's it's a six digit number so uh we
have a pretty huge data set for that
okay another question
okay you said you were using a beautiful
soup right for extracting or extracting
text or whatever from that specific URL
right uh for example for one million
rows or one million websites how much
time did it take for you to do so
we don't go much deep in the website
and also our current solution is based
only solely on the URL but in our
experiments uh for the beautiful soup
with a beautiful soup and scraping those
websites uh it is uh less than one
second uh
and we go only two pages deep not very
deep into the websites
[Music]
okay thanks for the talk and I was
wondering whether the like human given
feedbacks are used for retraining of the
model or not of course
there are feedbacks feedbacks from human
and they can be uh biased we just use it
for testing for project testing and
stuff like that okay thank you
foreign
there are actually two questions first
like how many data points did you have
and also the second one do you do any uh
data augmentation in some engineered way
like taking a legit domain domain name
and adding some malicious request
parameter to it Etc
uh the second one no we don't augment
our data because we have enough to train
our models
okay thank you
[Applause]